c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir la rencontre entre les
principaux partis politiques et le
Premier ministre en Guinée au menu la
mise en place d'un cadre de dialogues
pour une sortie de crise les détails
dans ce journal cette vague rouge dans
les rues de Johannesburg en Afrique du
Sud des milliers de travailleurs de la
fonction publique ont répondu à l'appel
à la grève de leur principale syndicat
il demande une augmentation de salaire
et à la fin de ce journal nous serons en
direct de charnel cher en Égypte où nous
interrogerons notre invité
l'alia Camara ministre mauritanienne de
l'environnement et du développement
durable qui participe à la COP 27
entretient à suivre
elle était très attendue cette rencontre
entre les principaux partis politiques
et le Premier ministre guinéen elle a eu
lieu cet après-midi à Conakry au menu
les conditions de la mise en place d'un
dialogue pour une sortie crise dans le
pays la correspondance de Malik Diakité
des partis politiques les plus influents
du pays qui avait jusque-là refusé de
rencontrer le Premier ministre parmi eux
le RPG arc-en-ciel le parti du président
dessus Alpha Condé la nature politique
dirigée par l'opposant Cellou Dalein
Diallo et le fndc politique au cours des
entretiens c'est leader politique ont
remis un rapport au Premier ministre
dans lequel ils exigent des conditions
préalables pour le participe à tout
dialogue nous avons demandé à ce que les
prisonniers politiques qui sont
incarcérés à la maison centrale soit
libérée nous avons demandé à ce que le
retour des exilés politiques nous avons
demandé également à ce que
l'interdiction de manifester soit levée
nous avons demandé à ce que l'acte qui a
été pris pour dissoudre le FND ce soir
rapporté mais nous avons également
demandé à ce que des enquêtes sérieuses
soient menées pour
identifier les auteurs des assassinats
lors des manifestations pendant le règne
du CNRD le Premier ministre dit avoir
pris bonne note des demandes de ces
interlocuteurs et ce que je peux vous
rassurer
[Musique]
un rapport de la part du coton et très
rapidement nous allons continuer en quoi
échanger pour que le cadre du dialogue
inclusif puisse effectivement de
démarrer dans les jours à venir reste à
savoir si les conditions posées par les
leaders politiques seront acceptés par
les militaires au pouvoir qui ont déjà
exprimé leur volonté de ne pas reculer
sous aucune pression
cette grève dans le secteur de la
fonction publique en Afrique du Sud ils
étaient des milliers à répondre à
l'appel d'un des plus importants
syndicats du secteur la publicoven
association elle compte quelques 235
000 adhérents Laurent Berthet
rassembler dans les rues de
Johannesbourg ils sont venus faire
entendre leur revendications
ces fonctionnaires sud-africains
estiment que le gouvernement ne les a
pas entendu et continue de réclamer une
augmentation salariale qu'ils estiment
nécessaire
nous avons besoin de cet argent il y a
encore de grandes disparités salariales
adjointes
dans plusieurs grandes villes d'Afrique
du Sud des fonctionnaires ont répondu à
l'appel d'un des plus importants
syndicats du pays en faisant grève ce
jeudi la semaine dernière le
gouvernement sud-africain avait annoncé
une hausse de 3% des salaires pour
l'ensemble de la fonction publique mais
les syndicats eux réclament une
augmentation de 6,5 % un chiffre qui
reste bien en deçà de l'inflation en
Afrique du Sud
ces deux dernières années nous avons
subi l'épidémie de covid-19 les prix des
denrées augmentent chaque jour mais les
travailleurs continuent de gagner le
même salaire qu'il y a 5 ans
le ministre des Finances a récemment
affirmé ne pas pouvoir dépasser les 3%
d'augmentation salariale mais les
fonctionnaires espèrent encore pouvoir
faire fléchir le gouvernement le mois
dernier un mouvement social avait
paralysé les gares et les ports
sud-africains provoquant des pertes à
hauteur de 44 millions d'euros par jour
pas de justice climatique sans droits
humains c'est ce que l'on pouvait lire
sur les banderoles d'une rare
manifestation à Charmelle cher en Égypte
ce jeudi ou se tient la COP 27 jusqu'au
18 novembre des activistes profitent de
la médiatisation de la conférence pour
réclamer la libération des détenus
d'opinion dont Allah abdelfatta en grève
de la fin et de la soif son état de
santé est très préoccupant
alors que les dirigeants du monde se
penchent sur le sort de la planète à
sharm-elcher pour la cop27 sur sur le
terrain les effets du réchauffement
climatique sont devenus le quotidien de
nombreuses populations en Centrafrique
ce sont les pêcheurs qui en pâtissent la
montée des eaux provoquée par les
inondations fait fuir les poissons
dans la brume grisonnante de l'Aube
Pacôme koyeké embarque sur sa pirogue et
jette ses filets dans le fleuve ou
bandit
soleil n'est pas encore levé mais ce
jeune pécheur est à la tâche depuis des
heures et désespèrent devant son maigre
butin jeux de petits poissons
alors on est là depuis trois heures du
matin
depuis le mois de juin la Centrafrique
fait face à des inondations
catastrophiques les changements de
courant ont fait fuir les poissons qui
partent se réfugier dans les mangroves
inaccessibles aux pécheurs ceux-ci se
retrouvent démunis et comme Pacôme
doivent souvent travailler à perte
au marché de Bangui les étals qui
regorgent habituellement de poissons
frais sont à moitié vides les clients
inspectent avec méfiance la marchandise
dont les prix ont plus que doublé
en temps normal on pourrait trouver du
poisson mais cette saison n'est pas
normale nous n'avons presque rien et le
peu que nous trouvons les prix sont
exorbitants mais les gens ne le savent
pas ils pensent qu'on leur vend le
poisson trop cher
la pénurie pourrait avoir de lourdes
conséquences sur l'économie
centrafricaine l'un des pays les plus
pauvres au monde où la pêche occupe une
place importante dans les communautés
rurales
et on continue de parler climat avec
notre invité en direct de charme el cher
la ministre mauritanienne de
l'environnement et du développement
durable madame Leila Lalia pardon Camara
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous on a
entendu ce reportage sur sur le poisson
et la raréfaction du poisson notamment
en Centrafrique le secteur de la pêche
est un moteur de l'économie
mauritanienne est-ce que cela vous
inquiète dans un futur proche ou un
temps de voir que le qui a de moins en
moins de poissons
bonsoir merci pour l'invitation tout à
fait nous subissons également en
Mauritanie le même phénomène comme vous
le savez la Mauritanie à 700 km de côte
c'est un des pays les plus poissonneux
d'Afrique de l'Ouest et d'ailleurs dans
le monde
et cette
denrée qui est une denrée précieuse pour
une population également pour nos
ressources en exportation sera réussi de
jour en jour les captures diminuent et
donc tout cela est également une
conséquence de la changement climatique
donc
non seulement dans cet état de la pêche
mais également de sortir de
l'agriculture dans le secteur de
l'élevage nous subissons les mêmes
conséquences qui sont la rarification
des ressources larification des
productions nationales et tout cela
Marc effectivement et démontre les
effets de changement climatique qui sont
très néfastes pour le continent africain
et pour la Mauritanie également en
particulier qui est un pays comme vous
le savez à 80% concile le désert immense
territoire certes
le désert et c'est des applications
s'accentue parce que les airs descend
vers le sud
nous subissons aujourd'hui une érosion
des sols qui est due également au
changement climatique et rejoindre du
sol les sols mais également disparition
de la végétation de la biodiversité
alors votre pays a pris des engagements
l'autre de la précédente Coop notamment
pour préserver la biodiversité que
venait de citer avez-vous pu mettre en
oeuvre vos projets ou attendez-vous
encore les promesses de don qu'elles se
concrétisent
tout à fait on est aujourd'hui à la
27ème Coop ce qui veut dire que cela
fait 27 ans que
la question du changement climatique des
effets néfastes des changements
climatiques sur nos écosystèmes sur
notre biodiversité et poser et que la
semaine d'alarme est tirée et le dernier
en année cette ce constat est fait pour
tous les pays africains et
malheureusement l'action sur le terrain
ne suit pas
la vulnérabilité dans le pays n'est plus
n'est plus approuvée nous le venons de
le voir mais l'action qui est celle de
la de la communauté internationale
ne suit pas les promesses sont faites on
parle de centaines de milliards de
dollars pour l'adaptation on parle de
vingtaine de milliards de dollars pour
un grand projet que nous avons à cœur
qui est là celle du projet de la Grande
muraille verte mais il est difficile
aujourd'hui pour les pays africains et
les pays qui ont la Mauritanie d'avoir
accès à ces financements hier la journée
de la COP a été consacrée à la finance
et c'est un sujet que nous avons débattu
avec mes collègues des pays d'Afrique
subsaharienne mais également notre
collègue également était là et il était
clairement
[Musique]
admis par tous qu'aujourd'hui la
complexité des mécanismes le manque de
vulgarisation de ces mécanismes amènent
les pays africains à être dans une
position d'attente des promesses faites
des engagements qui ont été tenus et qui
jusqu'à présent ne sont pas concrètement
vu sur le sur le terrain la Mauritanie
aujourd'hui
dispose une quarantaine de millions de
dollars pour ces différents projets et
différentes sur différents sujets donc
on est loin du besoin que nous avons
exprimé dans notre contribution
détermination nationale qui a été salué
par ses pairs en 2021 donc présenté en
2015 mais réactualisé en 2021 et cette
CDN
présente le dispositif de la stratégie
de la Mauritanie sur non seulement
l'atténuation mais également
l'adaptation et malheureusement sur le
terrain nous avons du mal à déployer la
mise en oeuvre de cette CDN faute de
moyens alors on parle ça c'est un
constat qui est unanime
alors on parle beaucoup de
l'exploitation du gaz au large des côtes
mauritaniennes conjointement avec le
Sénégal en pleine crise liée à la guerre
en Ukraine ou le gaz est très prisé que
répondez-vous à ceux qui vous disent
qu'il faut laisser tomber ces énergies
fossiles et vous développer autrement
je leur dis effectivement que le gaz
constitue une des ressources je dirais
dont dispose la Mauritanie le Sénégal
elle s'est les ressources qu'on nous
attendons depuis maintenant quelques
années et dont l'exploitation va
commencer en 2020
si tout va bien tout a été mis en oeuvre
pour cela le gaz est considéré comme une
énergie moins polluante que tous les
autres énergies fossiles et nous devons
absolument Mauritanie comme le Sénégal
profiter de cette ressource naturelle
que nous avons commun c'est une
ressource qui ne vous permettra non
seulement d'être indépendant et
énergétiquement mais également
d'engranger les ressources financières
qui vont justement nous permettre
d'aller vers des des énergies non
polluantes telles que les hydrogène vert
la Mauritanie aujourd'hui et c'était en
exemple dans son plan d'expansion de
production des jours de Jeunes Verts
nous avons des investisseurs qui sont
intéressés par cette par cette par cette
question nous avons trois grands trois
gros programmes qui sont en train d'être
mis en œuvre et donc le gaz va nous
permettre justement de passer d'une
énergie je dirais
[Musique]
verte aussi mais vers une énergie encore
plus encore plus
écologique donc la Mauritanie comme le
Sénégal ont besoin effectivement de se
production gazelle alors
qu'attendez-vous de cette COP pour votre
pays et pour le reste du continent
cette coop a été mise sous le gîte de la
de l'implémentation donc de la mise en
oeuvre et je m'en réjouis parce que
c'est aujourd'hui les unanime et tout le
monde
est d'accord dessus pour dire qu'on doit
passer à l'action nous avons beaucoup
d'engagements été pris beaucoup de
promesses ont été faites la semaine
dernière a été tirée sur ces dernières
années et donc aujourd'hui le fait de
passer vers une vers une implémentation
est une période est une assez positif
c'est un espoir pour tous maintenant
c'est un plan plantation ne se fera pas
tout seul les pays dit pollueurs et
c'est la réalité doivent maintenant
respecter leurs engagements je me
réjouis également que à cette COP le
message le message sur la justice
climatique soit également passée il est
admis par tous que aujourd'hui l'Afrique
ne produit que 4% moins de 4%, les gaz à
effet de serre la Mauritanie moins de
0,05% dont nous ne sommes pas des pulls
polluants mais c'est nous qui subissons
le plan fouet
les catastrophes naturelles que sont les
inondations la désertification les
chaleurs accablantes qui aujourd'hui
entraînent aux populations des
migrations des régions les plus chaudes
vers des grandes villes donc il est il
est plus que temps et donc nous aurez
juste aujourd'hui que le message soit
bien passé merci donc demain sera
meilleur merci votre message est passé
également merci beaucoup madame
Lalia Camara ministre mauritanien de
l'environnement et du développement
durable merci d'avoir été notre invité
on vous parle d'Africom l'événement
africain le plus important en matière de
tech il se tient au Cap jusqu'au 11
novembre de nombreux investisseurs
considèrent l'événement comme un énorme
potentiel coup de projecteur sur les
startups africaines avec notre
correspondante Caroline Dumay
plus de 10 000 personnes se sont donné
rendez-vous cette semaine pour parler
communication et technologie parmi les
secteurs les plus abordés l'extension de
la 5G la distribution satellite l'accès
du monde digital en zone rurale et aussi
les start-ups car si seulement 2% des
financements mondiaux vont vers les
startups africaines et bien le secteur
étant plein essor et les investisseurs
qui sont venus cette semaine chercher de
nouvelles opportunités sont très
optimistes quand on regarde le nombre de
dollars par habitant qui vont à des
startups en Afrique c'est vraiment rien
du tout on est de l'ordre de plus comme
7 ou 8 dollars alors que c'est peut-être
10 fois plus dans d'autres régions par
exemple en Inde mais ça augmente en 2022
l'écosystème de startup africain va être
le seul à montrer de la croissance par
rapport à 2021 en terme de levée de
fonds dans le monde les startupeurs
africains étaient nombreux pour venir
pitcher leur projet
celui-là elle travaille sur la
téléphonie mobile 70% des personnes qui
payent leurs factures par téléphone sont
des Africains le potentiel est énorme
si vous avez un produit et que vous le
gardez chez vous il ne sert à rien il
faut le montrer c'est le seul moyen de
se faire connaître et avec un peu de
chance vous vous trouvez un sponsor et
ça profite à tout le monde les startups
africaines ont attiré cette année plus
de 5 milliards d'euros et si le tiers
des fonds provient encore des États-Unis
de plus en plus d'investisseurs
africains prennent le risque de financer
les entrepreneurs de leur continent
c'est la fin du journal de l'Afrique
restez avec nous l'info continue sur
France 24
[Musique]